salut tout le monde je suis tom holland vous pourriez
me reconnaître comme votre
sympathique spider-man de quartier et je suis ici pour
vous dire que spidey est de retour pour une
toute nouvelle aventure dans spider-man no way
home je sais que les gens le disent beaucoup mais je
veux dire  c'est quand je dis que vous allez
voir des choses dans ce film que vous n'avez
jamais vues auparavant, je parle de
bombes à la citrouille
tempête de sable
le multivers qui d'accord vous les avez peut-être déjà
vus auparavant mais je promets
pas comme ça et pas ensemble  aussi
Peter Parker se dirige enfin vers l'
université et le mot est sorti, alors oui,
tout le monde sait qu'il est un homme araignée,
alors jetez vos théories de fans par la
fenêtre, elles ne sont probablement pas vraies ou le sont-
elles
et préparez-vous à voir l'un des plus
des films ambitieux, nous avons déjà fait une
histoire incroyable avec beaucoup de rires cardiaques,
une action de haut vol, des effets époustouflants
et des méchants insensés.
y ici toute la journée
c'est tellement fou là-bas
enfin un peu d'intimité c'est tellement fou là-bas est-
ce qu'une partie de vous se sent soulagée vous
n'avez pas vraiment à vous cacher tout le monde
connaît spiderman mais dans ma vie c'était
parfait quand tu l'as découvert  tous les deux
on s'aime on raccroche j'ai besoin de mes
huit heures tu as écouté
tout ce temps pas par choix
toi